parte ve escribe los primeros cuatro
términos distintos de cero de la serie
de mclaren para f prima la derivada de f
expresa a efe prima como una función
racional para el valor absoluto de x
menor que el radio nuestro radio de
convergencia y bueno anoté acá abajo en
nuestra serie de maturín para que
podamos trabajarla y ahora lo que vamos
a buscar es la serie de matt loring para
f prima así que déjenme anotarlo vamos a
buscar la serie de matt loring la serie
de marketing de marketing para
efe prima de x es decir que si esta de
arriba es mi fx mi función de x entonces
lo que voy a hacer por aquí es tomarme
la derivada de esa función y bueno esto
me va a quedar lo mismo que la serie la
serie desde n igual a uno hasta infinito
de y bueno si esta es la expresión para
mi función de x lo que voy a hacer es
tomarme la derivada de esto y si
observas es simplemente aplicar la regla
de la potencia entonces tomas este
exponente y lo multiplicas por el
coeficiente que es todo esto de aquí
pero observa si multiplicamos a n por
todo esto entre n bueno
n por 1 entre n se cancela y nos queda
simplemente menos 3
3 esto elevado a la potencia en menos 1
y después hay que quitarle uno a nuestro
exponente entonces nos quedan x elevado
a la n 1 x elevado a la n menos uno
y quiero ser muy claro en esto lo único
que hice fue aplicar la regla de la
potencia me tome esta potencia de aquí
déjame atraparlo con este color me tome
esta potencia de aquí y la multiplique
por todo este coeficiente que tengo aquí
y observa como tengo una n dividiendo y
una n multiplicando esas dos se van a
cancelar y simplemente me voy a quedar
con menos 3 elevado a la enee menos uno
que es esta parte de aquí y después hay
que bajarle uno a la potencia entonces
me va a quedar x elevado a la n menos 1
esta es una regla fundamental para las
derivadas y es las primeras reglas que
se aprenden al derivar entonces si
queremos escribir los primeros cuatro
términos distintos de cero para nuestra
serie de mack loring de la derivada de
fx entonces que nos va a quedar bueno
primero quiero que observes que aquí
tenemos la misma potencia en este y en
este de aquí eso quiere decir que esto
lo puedo escribir de la siguiente manera
esto es lo mismo que tomarme la serie
desde n igual a 1 desde n igual a 1
hasta infinito de y bueno en lugar de
escribir estos dos por separado
voy a unidos en un solo paréntesis menos
3x y voy a elevar todo a la n 1 muy bien
esto es más fácil de trabajar y entonces
esto va a ser aproximadamente
aproximadamente porque recuerda solo nos
vamos a tomar los primeros 4 términos
distintos de cero de esta serie que
tengo aquí y ahora sí sí queremos los
primeros cuatro términos que me va a
quedar y bueno no sesione que van aquí
así que mejor lo voy a escribir acá
abajo esto va a ser aproximadamente
aproximadamente y que pasa cuando en er
tal uno bueno cuando n vale 1 me va a
quedar uno menos uno lo cual es cero y
cualquier cosa elevada a la cero
así que me va a quedar uno más y después
que pasan cuando n vale 2
aquí me quedaría 2 - 1 lo cual es 1 y
entonces tengo menos 3x elevado a la
primera potencia lo cual bueno es menos
3x menos 3x y que pasa cuando n vale 3
bueno aquí me quedaría 3 - 1 lo cual es
2 y entonces tengo que elevar al
cuadrado
al menos 3 x lo cual es bueno menos 3 al
cuadrado es 9 positivo y después me
quedaría x cuadrada muy bien y qué pasa
cuando n vale 4 aquí me va a quedar 4
menos uno lo cual es 3 y menos 3 x al
cubo es lo mismo que menos 27
x ubica perfecto así que ya está esta es
la primera parte de este inciso escribe
los primeros cuatro términos distintos
de cero de la serie de mclaren para f
prima aquí está y bueno ojo también
podrías obtenerlos desde aquí es lo
mismo que tomarnos la derivada de cada
uno de estos y decir por ejemplo para
los primeros cuatro términos que la
derivada de x bueno esto es 1 la tengo
justo aquí la derivada de menos tres
medios de x cuadrada bueno eso es lo
mismo por la derivada de una potencia
bajamos la potencia y me quedan menos 3x
y después puedes ver que la derivada de
este de aquí de 3x cúbica es lo mismo
que 9 x cuadrada la tenemos aquí y pasa
lo mismo para el cuarto término podrías
desarrollarlo y calcular su derivada
bien ahora vayamos a la segunda parte
que dice escribe a efe prima como una
función racional para el valor absoluto
d
es menor que ere y bueno si suponemos
que esta serie de aquí está serie de
aquí convergen y bueno ya sabemos su
radio de convergencia o más bien si
suponemos que tratamos con una equis que
tiene un radio de convergencia entonces
esta serie de aquí déjame bajar un poco
la pantalla para terminar este inciso
entonces esta serie de aquí esta de aquí
déjame escribirla de nuevo la serie
desde
igual a uno hasta infinito de bueno
tengo menos 3
x esto elevado a la enee menos 1
quiero que observes que esto de aquí es
exactamente lo mismo que tomarme una
serie pero que ahora empieza en cero es
decir me voy a tomar la serie desde n
igual y ahora voy a empezar en cero
desde n igual a cero hasta infinito y
ahora lo que voy a hacer es bajarle uno
al exponente es decir de menos 3 x
elevado a la ella tal vez lo pueda
reconocer de esta manera observa si n
vale 1 en este caso me quedaría uno
menos uno lo cual es cero y aquí si n
vale cero entonces aquí me queda cero de
manera directa entonces estas dos series
son exactamente lo mismo lo único que
hice fue cambiar el límite inferior de
esta serie y ahora puedes reconocer a
esta de aquí como una serie geométrica
con una razón común
3x de menos 3x y bueno cual es la suma
de una serie geométrica con una razón
común conocida y bueno esto es
exactamente lo mismo que me tomó el
primer término de esta serie que ya lo
sabemos es 11 ya eso lo divido entre 1 -
la razón común pero nosotros ya sabemos
que menos 3x esto de aquí es la razón
común entonces me quedaría uno menos
menos 3x y bueno menos menos 3 x eso lo
podemos poner como uno más 3 x así que
ya puedo decir que esta serie geométrica
de aquí va a ser exactamente igual que
esto que tengo aquí que es la respuesta
de la segunda parte de este inciso y si
esto te es poco familiar encargo que
veas los vídeos de series geométricas
porque lo único que hice fue aplicar la
fórmula y si quieres saber cómo sé
a esta fórmula lo cual es bastante
divertido entonces ve a ver los vídeos
al respecto de cualquier manera ahora
podemos ver a esta serie que teníamos de
mclaren como una serie geométrica de
esta forma y suponiendo que nuestra x
tiene un radio de convergencia entonces
así es como se ve en nuestra serie a
esto vamos a converger